I'm here with the wonderful folks from
amplitude Studio gonna be talking about
the upcoming 4x strategy game humankind
thanks gentlemen for joining me all the
way from sunny France is it yes Paris
today most of this Sun but you know as a
huge strategy nerd I'm super excited
about then your next entry into the
genre really but I wanted to kind of
give a heads-up to anyone that's just
just getting familiar with the series
again with a new franchise even one of
your big big selling points is that you
have so many cultures that you can draw
from gain influences or players can you
tell us how many cultures you're tapping
into and the scale of these cultures so
we have 60 different cultures in the
game you know through like six different
eras so ten cultures per area and yeah
basically it's time you know you move on
to an era you can actually decide if you
want to evolve to one of this culture
and actually you can start combining all
these cultures together to be able to
create your own nation and so if you do
the math that's up to 1 million possible
civilizations that you can build out of
that list of 60 cultures and you could
have like different ways of you know
deciding how to evolve you know is it
because you want to recreate history
because you want to adapt yourself to a
given situation maybe I'd love to start
with like exploration of science and
being of the game so you know I can
think the Babylonians we can evolve if I
want for science and and you know as you
move on you know maybe I will have other
challenges and try to adapt you family
or maybe try to have a little combo like
to try to maximize maybe nice I want
States you to decide who you want to
become more than anything from what I've
seen so far apart from the huge draw of
multiculturalism and you guys are really
talking about the fame of the culture
that you're creating can you tell us a
little more about what fame means in
humankind yeah well Fame it's
for us a way to look at your journey
basically it's all about whenever you
write history no you will have you know
these achievements these feats that
people will remember about you you know
in the future and that's that's famous
okay so whenever you play the game if
you do something memorable you know
that's you know where you develop more
Fame and with fame actually you'll be
able to move through history you'll be
able to become you know or as you know
more cultures to your initial culture
but it's also you know when you're rich
standpoint you know it was the end of
the game to be able to look at all the
paths you know and and see what a
wonderful history you're written it's
not about who you are at the end of the
game it's really but who you have been
throughout the game yes so famous
basically how you know we measure the
mark you have left on history and it's
about being remembered not just having
the biggest army or the biggest empire
at the end of the game so if for
instance in arrows 1 & 2 you're a master
of exploration and science and you
basically dominate an entire continent
with your culture and then come era for
the early modern age and suddenly an
army crosses the ocean and crushes you
well you might still win the game
because what you did before that was
more memorable and left a bigger mark on
the history of humankind so yeah that's
really a way for us to to to it's a new
take on the 4x sauna and and big victory
conditions and one that we are confident
will resonate with how we live and how
we look at history today imagine you
know when that invasion comes you are
playing an agrarian culture okay so with
your affinity you get this ability to
steal population from nearby territories
or to
have a new population pop up faster in
your in your empire well if you get
invaded and you're nearing the end of an
era you might decide to you know earn a
bit more fame to get access to the next
era quicker choose a military culture
which gives you the ability to convert
your population into militia as much as
you want and counter the attack so you
know the example was just to you know to
let you know how you know leaving your
mark is more important than just winning
bigger battles but it doesn't mean
you're not able to you know to reverse
the tide at at any moment and basically
fame the way it's earned there's two key
ways to earn Fame one we called we call
world deeds and the second is error
stars so world deeds is basically a big
amount of achievements that are
accessible to all players on the map so
for instance be the first to chart your
entire continent or be the first to
cross the sea first to found a religion
and what not many many examples and when
you get that and you're the first to get
that then you're being famous for
instance if you you're the first one to
research writing and you invented
writing that's a pretty big mark left on
history and error stars are basically a
mechanic whereby we have seven different
affinities in the game and each of these
affinities gets a set of goals of stars
that they can unlock that they can reach
and basically if you unlock seven of any
type of stars at your company competing
for then you get to access the next era
so world leads our stars are what will
build your fame you can build your fame
the way you want fry it that's it's
completely up to science through war
explorations and and and again it's all
about thinking ahead
and thinking of the combos that you're
gonna be making between the cultures and
what ever the dynamic of one error might
not be the one of the next and you might
you know there's there's many ways that
you can again reverse the type or adapt
your play style to the challenges you're
facing at any given time so is there a
penalty to being not having any fame a
penalty for low fame or a buff for if
you are the most famous culture in a
game or something so we actually we have
a mechanic that you know I won't go into
the details today but we we have
catch-up mechanics we do have catch-up
mechanics and some arrow stars become
easier to achieve four players are
really lagging behind
of course it this needs to be balanced
and you need to you know have incentives
to be always ahead of the game but we do
have those mechanics when we're not
really into punishment you know I don't
think you're playing a 4x4 like 10 or 20
hours to be punished all the time so
it's not really what we want to do but
it's true with that system you know you
definitely are encouraged to try to to
achieve things but you have so many
different ways of doing it that's it's
nearly impossible not to win anything
it's just you know what's going to be
some people will faint faster than you
and that's it maybe all that means it's
in the ends maybe you will not be the
one to be remembered like that game
maybe you'll have to play again to try
to make more fun you've you've talked a
lot about the historical authenticity of
the game during development that you're
kind of creating authentic building
blocks that players can then put
together in their own way how much of
the the deeds and the stars stuff how is
how much of that are like real
historical events versus how much is it
is it like player driven or player
agency created it's definitely more
player driven but I think the way we try
to look at it is to think if you know
that has you know that
history you know would you have mark
history with that you know and if the
answer was yes then then then you will
have fame for it
and and there's many ways to make
history of course but obviously you have
some you know bigger ways to marketer
than others again every block in the
game is historically authentic but a lot
of the experience is driven by player
agency so you know you might create a
civilization that has middle-eastern
roots but then grows into Western Europe
and then Asia and then you know it and
to some it might seem like okay this is
not historically accurate but this is
where your own fantasy comes into play
you are able to build your own
civilization drawing from the cultures
that you seem the most interesting the
more most powerful the most charismatic
the ones that yield the most benefits
it's really up to you but if you dive if
you delve into the specifics and you
know you we have historical we're
working with historians documenting
every aspect of the game and you'll get
a lot of information on every culture in
the game
its history we're focusing on the bits
of history that also reflect the
gameplay inclination for those cultures
so it all makes sense within the system
of the game so yes every block is
circular fencing but a lot of room for
customization yeah we try make sure it's
always justified do you also have kind
of historical events that appear in the
game or is it more so discoveries and
inventions so we definitely have a lot
of events inspired by history what we
what wanted to avoid was to have the
exact event you know but obviously all
the events we added in the game in we
have a lot in them we always try to of
course have a strong inspiration from
real history
and often you all recognize what it is
but then you know in front of this
moment in situations you know you will
be able to take your own decision on how
to places basically events will be
triggered by your play style again so
they're all inspired by historical
events like every one of them but
they're not a specific event but for
instance if and they're all relevant to
their error the error that they pop in
so for instance if you're building all
these farmlands next to a river well
after 10 turns for instance maybe a
flood will occur and then you will need
to deal with the the flood and you know
you'll get you'll be presented with the
lure for the choice and also then the
the various tenses that you can take you
can make a choice this will in turn
impact the geology system which we'll
talk about at another time and those
events actually also echo through time
because some of them will have
consequences like across the entire
history it the entire six errors so yeah
we're pretty really happy with the event
system obviously the fame systems quite
a unique troll and that you guys have to
the Forex genre where did the idea for
fame and this whole system come from the
idea behind it was I think it was to
find a way whether it was not very
artificial to talk about history you
know in a game I wanted to to reward the
past not just a presence so and and it's
in you know what we've done quite a few
four axes so far and and we played you
know a lot of other you know 4x games
and it's true that's you know you always
have that feeling that you are rewarded
for the last turn of the game
and for me this is not history its
history it's all about reading but this
amazing moments from the past of things
that happens things you know you can be
proud of or make you dream or make you
you know travel and and and you know you
just wanted to be able to play any of
these past cultures and say if I do
something now you know people are you
later we'll remember that moments you
know and this is for what I do now you
know that that's what matters and and
even if you know my my country your
culture disappears or declined you know
we still remember that making history
and I think we have a lot of that in the
history of you know these amazing
cultures and countries that sometimes
have disappeared
or the left an amazing history and that
that we will still remember you know
through you know the the yeah but they
left over for us to to to be able to
contemplate or read about sand which is
amazing so yeah it's and and I think
it's a great way to attach a place where
there's the old cliche of the history
being written by the victor play a part
in this is there a way to kind of remove
someone else's Fame and scour them from
history in a way that that sentence will
be true because I think we'll remember
differently who has the most pain at the
end of the game and maybe you get inside
to adjust the own Fame and you know hone
the history if you warm probably if you
know you had not the most famous night
just play again and forget about that
game but be not forget because you have
more the biggest moments of it but no
it's it's yeah will be the case but we
don't have any mechanics gaming kind of
stuff to to try to to take away some of
the same to burn the books you know that
are talking about you know your your
enemy or it's not not really the way
this actually it is extremely hard to to
raise the flame of someone in Disraeli
already you know it's like someone did
something in famous of famous basically
you all remember it the same way you
know and people won't talk about it you
know we still thinking about Attila and
and and and you know and I get hit in
years later so no yeah it's uh it's it's
all about remembering whoever you are in
whatever you did and yes we remember
more the victors
that one's super exciting sounds like a
an amazing new take on the on the Forex
onra can you tell us when we can get our
hands on humankind now next year next
year we were actually are supposed to be
come to come out a bit earlier but yeah
I think we're not the only ones we did
suffer bit from the situation and we
decided to take some time basically to
we definitely expect to be affected by
the recovered situation for a bit longer
so we're all working from home you know
and it's not easy for everyone so so we
think the time you are very lucky to
have secured with us who allows us to to
take the time to to polish the game you
know for longer and and and make sure
basically we can come out feel innovates
ready great well thank you guys so much
for taking the time out especially in
this strange situation to come and talk
about humankind and I will definitely be
keeping track of everything that you're
coming up with in the future then also
anyone else out there watching if you
want to learn more about humankind to
keep up to date then GameSpot is the
exact place you should you should be
hanging out thank you guys so much your
time bye-bye thank you
you
[Music]